lo que quiero introducirte en este vídeo
es la noción de lo que es una relación
proporcional o que hay una relación
proporcional y esencialmente una
relación proporcional es justamente
digamos una relación donde tenemos dos
variables y la proporción entre esas dos
variables de las que estamos hablando
siempre va a ser el mismo número así que
veamos un ejemplo para que sea mucho más
claro digamos que tenemos una relación
entre dos variables digamos que tenemos
una relación entre la variable x y la
variable y entonces digamos que cuando x
es 1 la variable y estrés cuando x es 2
la variable 6 y vámonos a un caso
extremo digamos que cuando la variable x
es 9 entonces la variable ya es 27 ok
entonces lo que queremos ver es que este
ejemplo es una relación proporcional
verdad y eso lo vamos a ver porque el
cociente o la razón entre jay x
es siempre la misma es una constante ok
o bien podríamos hacerlo de equis entre
ella pero vamos a hacerlo primero con y
entre x esta es la razón que hay entre i
y x y por ejemplo cuando vale 3 entonces
x vale 1 esa es nuestra primera digamos
nuestro primer número pero por ejemplo
cuando y cuando ya vale 6
entonces x vale 2 y 6 entre dos es tres
que es lo mismo que teníamos
anteriormente y cuando vale 27 x vale 9
y 27 entre 9 vuelve a ser nuevamente 3
verdad entonces tenemos que entre x es
siempre 3 siempre es 3 verdad y por
supuesto es con base en estos datos
verdad no tenemos más datos pero con
estos es suficiente para creer que la
relación que hay entre jay x es
justamente una relación proporcional
verdad así que veamos ahora un ejemplo
en donde no haya una relación
proporcional digamos que tenemos ahora 2
la variable ah ok tenemos una variable a
y una variable b y ahora digamos que
cuando a vale 1
perdón me vale 3 cuando a vale 2 b vale
6 pero cuando a vale 10 b vale 35 ok
entonces vamos a ver qué pasa con el
cociente o la división de b entre a la
razón que hay entre veía entonces de
entregar por ejemplo cuando b vale 3 a
vale 1 y tenemos tres entre 1 que es 3
pero cuando ve vale 6 entonces a vale 2
y hasta este momento tú dirás bueno
parece ser una relación proporcional
verdad porque se dice entre dos estrés
que también es 3 entre 1 sin embargo
esto ya no es igual a 35 entre 10 que es
el caso cuando b vale 35 y ya vale 10
entonces ésta
no es una relación proporcional no es
proporcional así que la clave para
distinguir una relación proporcional
está en que el cociente o la razón entre
las dos variables debe ser siempre el
mismo valor verdad por ejemplo y entre x
debe ser siempre el mismo valor de entre
a en este caso no siempre es el mismo
verdad quizás también pudimos haberlo
hecho al revés no necesariamente entre x
por ejemplo qué hubiera pasado si
hubiéramos tomado x entre y bueno cuando
x vale 1 lleva al de 3 así que el primer
número es un tercio cuando x vale 2
entonces lleva al de seis y dos sextos
es igual a un tercio y cuando x vale 9
entonces que vale 27 así que si te das
cuenta todas todas estas proporciones o
todas estas razones son la misma verdad
así que esto también nos dice que no
importa cuál tomemos y entre xx entre
ella
el cociente o la razón debe ser la misma
en este primer caso vale 3 pero en este
segundo caso vale un tercio